yes we are with Levon aronian oh very
special very special very special I want
to welcome uh back to the show tell us
about today's game against Wesley it was
short but it was full of content
um I'm not sure about the countdown of
course the position is very playable
because it's the end so I think this is
uh
variation that is maybe underestimated
because it's kind of interesting to play
with white this idea with E4 right yeah
yeah generally before and he responded
with probably the most topical line
Bishop to B4
yeah and uh
yeah I took a look at it uh sometime I
think the skin gauge one you know the
point is of kingish one is I want to
meet Knight D4 B4
okay so you don't have this yeah
and if you take you take on C5 yeah and
this is a good structure for me yeah
yeah that makes a lot of sense so here
black has many options I mean A6 Castle
A5
I mean in every case you have to play
very differently because with the pawn
on A5 you can't afford to play Queen A1
but it will Pawn only six all these
lines are very very dangerous because
black and long castle at some point and
just start the attack so in order for
you to attack you also have to be ready
for him to cast along with the pawn on
A6 yeah but not with the pawn on A5 yeah
because the pawn 95 is going to be
hanging it's going to be like some sort
of a hook a3b4 you know the Knight goes
somewhere might be 595 yeah yeah this
time makes a lot of sense and you play
this move Queen to E1 Knight D4 Bishop
D1 very nice uh regrouping G3 and all he
came up with this yeah I think
aggressive H5 it's not a gross it's more
strategical because if black castles
then F4 is very unpleasant now then F5
G4 this type of things F5 G4 and if you
take of course take and Rook F3 Rook G3
yeah
this is not looking good
and he played H5 you responded were you
by the way still in your preparation no
no I thought you know if I play uh
I play F4 I thought well you know after
96 that was an interesting moment I
thought that four is the most topical
and then uh he probably has to take EF
because if Knight F4 Bishop F4 e e f and
E5 I E5
and thanks 0.65 and if Queen E7 Bishop
A4
C6 through K1
yeah yeah and he cannot play Bishop E3
because I take and Rook F4 she cannot
take because of rookie one up and maybe
1955 the game is over yeah that's very
nice actually
yeah everything comes with Tempo yeah so
it's I thought it's very very dangerous
to take with the night but I rejected it
mainly on the grounds of e take half
yes
um
yes and uh well now I cannot take Visa
before Knight F4 no more E5 yeah so I
have to play Knight D5
and here I felt Castle
and then you know Knight F4 Knight F4
Bishop before and Bishop D4 actually
before Mike should be fine here it's a
very strong Bishop on D4 protecting the
king side as well and you play the move
G3 no I thought that G3 is not the way
to go but somehow I felt after it for
there's nothing so I didn't really
remember what I was planning to do here
and here yeah you know
um application for C5 I mean Bishop D4 I
think is the right setup because the
point is
he wants to meet F4 with Knight C5
and then uh you know it's kind of
awkward I have to defend this pawn and
then he might try for a four two and
then a four a three ideas yeah
so F4 I don't think is a very
and you're actually not that fast on
this side either it seems like um yeah
yeah with your of course I I can do it
on move number 14 you know instead of
King G2
play it for here Bishop maybe if I was
to play F4 of course I had to do it here
but then Bishop D4 same I'm also not so
sure I'm I'm really doing any progress
here on on the king side of Knight C5
once again yeah F5 is logical and if
Knight E2 he can always play Bishop C5
he's also waiting you know
so maybe I can play it with Knight G1
but I wasn't not so sure
some strategical position black can you
know try to play Knight D4 and Knight G4
I mean if if I was in a in a better uh
shape I would definitely
you know try to
play on and create some battle but at
this moment I'm trying to minimize the
damage what would you say is the main
factor that caused let's say this drop
in shape for you oh I think I played too
much at some point it was
yeah it made me tired so I just need
some
I think a week of rest and I'm back on
back on a horse
for sure and tomorrow actually is a rest
day what are you going to do during the
rest day what's the plan
oh just uh you know walk around maybe uh
you know go for a little jog stuff like
that absolutely guys any questions for
uh Levant no absolutely Lavon uh get
your rest recharge your batteries come
out strong for the last three rounds
we're not going to make lemon tart
you're not gonna torture no absolutely I